el suministro del gas ruso enciende las
alarmas en europa alemania activó la
fase de alerta temprana de un plan de
emergencia ante el temor de un eventual
desabastecimiento
funcas quiero aprovechar también esta
declaración de la alerta temprana con un
llamamiento a los industriales y a los
consumidores privados para que nos
ayuden para que ayuden a alemania para
que ayuden a ucrania ahorrando gas y
energía en general ahora en aquí en sant
james pan alemán ya que depende hasta en
un 40% del gas ruso no logrará la
independencia total de los hidrocarburos
de moscú antes de mediados de 2024 un
panorama preocupante para muchos en el
'viejo continente' cuya dependencia del
gas ruso está lejos de solucionarse
países bajos pedirá a sus ciudadanos ya
sus negocios reducir el consumo mientras
que otros más dependientes como polonia
se muestran más desafiantes planea
cortar la importación de carbón para
mayo y poner fin a las importaciones de
petróleo ruso para fines de 2022 en un
contexto de crisis moscú insiste en su
plan de pedir países que califica de
inamistosos paguen sus exportaciones en
rublos y no en dólares o euros como
hasta ahora
teniendo en cuenta que el prestigio de
por ejemplo el dólar como principal
moneda de reserva mundial se ha visto
bastante quebrantado en los últimos años
la única inevitable alternativa a estos
procesos será la de usar monedas locales
los miembros del g7 rechazaron la medida
alegando un incumplimiento de contratos
ya firmados una eventual interrupción
del suministro afectaría a industrias y
amenazaría a la calefacción de millones
de hogares en europa pero el kremlin no
se detiene este miércoles el presidente
de la duma rusa dijo que la misma medida
del pago en rublos debería aplicarse a
otras exportaciones como los
fertilizantes los granos los metales o
la madera